welcome back uk airlines have been
warned to cancel flights they can't
sustain this summer to avoid causing
travel chaos the warning comes after
tens of thousands of holidaymakers were
affected by delays and cancellations
last month which they blamed on staff
shortages uh joining us now the
independence travel editor simon calder
simon lovely to see you this morning and
i unfortunately was unable to watch the
committee hearing uh committee hearings
yesterday um as i was asleep frankly so
tell us what we heard from from the
airlines well was there an awful lot of
contrition on display by any chance
well there was um depending which
airline you talked to so tui the biggest
holiday company in the uk which
obviously also um has an airline of its
own
you will recall the terrible scenes we
saw on sky news at the start of the main
end of may bank holiday with all sorts
of people finding out quite often on the
plane that their holiday had been
cancelled it was in the words of uh the
uh boss of tui dave burling he said it
was unacceptable we also heard from
british airways that they are cancelling
a lot of flights because they don't have
enough uh resources but they stopped
short of from confirming that this was
due to the ten thousand or so people
they uh let go during the uh kobit
pandemic and easyget said well yeah we
are cancelling some flights but we're
doing our best
what's happened overnight is that the
department for transport here in central
london and the civil aviation authority
have written to the airlines with a very
stern warning and a lot of people will
be saying well thank goodness at last
because uh this could have been sent
this uh strongly worded letter from the
director general of aviation here at the
dft and also the uh chief executive of
the caa it says we cannot have any more
of these unacceptable scenes and you are
going to have to help us quote de-risk
the summer to make sure that your flying
programs are deliverable
now that so we've had sorry simon so
we've had both so we've had both the
department for transport tui and and
presumably others saying this was
unacceptable i mean i suppose the
question is was it avoidable however
uh well it was uh to use that terrible
cliche a perfect storm of course what we
have seen is that um since the end of
the well at the end of the kobe
pandering the end of the travel
restrictions um of course uh well you
the transport secretary grant church
himself said hooray we can all go on
holiday as we used to which is um
terrific except it's not quite true
because the airlines having been crushed
by the travel restrictions and the kovic
pandemic um are
clearly were not in sufficient state to
run the schedules they had proposed now
some of them are doing absolutely uh
fine um there was a big shout out from a
lot of people to uh ryanair and jet too
who've been running everything um pretty
much according to schedule the odd delay
here or there occasionally a
cancellation but british airways and
easyjet are cancelling flights uh in
extraordinary numbers so ba have
cancelled um more than 100 shortfall
european and domestic flights today but
they cancelled those generally two or
three weeks ago and gave people plenty
of warning easyjet have cancelled over
40 flights to and from gatwick airport
today and uh they quite often only gave
people a few days and maybe in some
cases a few hours noticed and this
letter neil is aimed squarely at easyjet
the part which says you've got to have a
deliverable uh schedule and that means
if you have an easyjet booking this
summer you shouldn't be amazed to get an
email saying oh you were booked on the
nine o'clock to malaga on the 7th of
august well that's now uh cancelled but
you can go at seven o'clock in the
morning or um one o'clock in the
afternoon there will be lots of that
happening i understand over the next few
days possibly the next week but most
people will still be able to get where
they need to be so do not panic and
don't take a refund they have to offer
you an alternative flight either on
their own airline or if they haven't got
space on the day they have to find you a
flight with somebody else
simon fantastic advice as always mine is
simply go and top your tan up this week
just in case you don't get away that's
what i'm doing after i come off here
simon calder lovely to see you thanks
for being with us